[Music]
all right morty you ready for our
adventure to the lost city of atlantis
rick and morty not being complete
[ __ ] to each other is a pretty clear
indicator that we won't be going to
atlantis and i get that's the point of
the episode but it doesn't make me any
less upset that the episode does not
contain an adventure to the lost city of
atlantis also we're three seasons in and
still no one's picked up this [ __ ]
sock we're going from reality to reality
asking ricks to contribute charity
canvassing canvassing hey the brits and
the aussies went with charity muggers
and then a shortened version of that so
now there's been bad word choices on
three continents you're pitching the
policeman's ball to a black teenager
here the smartest man in the universe
being aware of the complex and difficult
relationship racial and ethnic
minorities have with the police but
choosing to use the topic as fodder for
his jokes as opposed to actually doing
something about it you don't have to be
a dick i think you know that's not true
when rick stop being polite and start
getting real we wouldn't dare play the
music but the sin as always is joe walsh
eating sardines while driving or pretty
much ever also drinking and driving
citadel morning news news about the
citadel in the morning pretty
self-explanatory when you over explain
things to the different versions of
yourself as if you're the [ __ ] and
before you say what about the mortys you
and i both know they'll never stop
playing with their remote long enough to
watch the news 60 iterations off the
central finite curve there's a rick that
works more with wood than polarity
plating the subtitles on my version say
this narrator sam elliott when it's
actually jeff b davis doing an
impression of sam elliott now whether
that's a mistake or a joke i'm giving it
a sin for making me take the time to
figure it out but also jeff p davis
absolutely nails this sam elliott
impression and the chemical that makes
his brain secrete goes into every simple
rick simple wafers wafer cookie brain
secretion wafer cookies are my least
favorite secretion way for cookies come
home to the impossible flavor of your
own completion tagline of my sex tape
the arrow on that this guy needs a
plumbus sign is not making it clear as
to exactly who needs the plumbus i love
being your new farty kids having an
entire factory that only makes wafer
cookies sure a factory could put out
just one product but [ __ ] wafer
cookies how is there a big enough market
for those k-83 affectionately known as
cool rick k83 doesn't pronounce his name
cool herrick just four normal mortys
normal put it in your blog shop owner
morty is suddenly clever enough to make
this comeback when a moment ago he
wasn't clever enough to give training
day rick and morty any information about
the robbery beyond saying they looked
like mortys the morty town locos making
your gang name sound hispanic by adding
the word logos to it is like the social
science equivalent of adding the word
quantum to things to make them more
sciency more lasers agreed how would you
solve the citadel's financial crisis for
a show as consistently outside the box
as this one and surprising they went
with a boilerplate financial crisis as a
problem facing the citadel i mean at
least give us a financial time crisis
can we fact check this please juggling
would have been enough but this one's
for attempting to fact check a juggling
metaphor when they dismiss class
everyone but these four just walked out
of the room and presumably out of the
building using the front door so why
couldn't these four do the same i see it
in our factories where ricks work for a
fraction of their boss's salary even
though they're identical and have the
same iq if they all have the same iq
then why aren't there robot servants
doing all the work and thousands of
ricks just sitting around drinking
margaritas shonies what else would i
send here everything else about this
scene's perfectly normal this screen in
the back shows all the rick's running
for office and their percentage in the
polls which equals 100 but where's the
morty date in his percentage even if he
has zero percent at this point he should
still be on this screen since he was
taking part in the debate i believe the
sin here is rick's crimination you gonna
lick my balls or what [ __ ] grandson you
keep me peeling squab squams and
slipping nib nibs i'll lick whatever
ain't nailed down well there's just a
lot of here i'm just gonna ignore for my
own sanity and move straight to sitting
rick for licks crimination against
things that are nailed down bandaging
your wound on the outside of your
clothes
hey y'all get the hell away from my damn
mega fruit mega fruit seeds didn't go up
a button this episode i bet the wishing
portal leads to a reality where they're
we're all where it's a bunch of french
toast with boobies does the french toast
have boobies or are the boobies on the
side i need to know slick why do you
have to be so dramatic episode has a
slick morty but no slick rick i thought
i was left-handed morty then you should
use your left hand to eat more
vegetables lizardmorty would be tv sins
morty at well tv sins associating food
with a hard rick is not a health code
violation in this scene one dance for
ten two for twenty five for a moment i
was worried about shaming autosexuality
here but the longer i spend with this
scene the more certain i become that
this is something else entirely i want
to be a regular kid i want to go to
school and throw balls around and
masturbate joe wants me to believe those
last two aren't one in the same
we got your portal gun after he drops
the shield they make a little baby
portal to give him the gun so while he
is distracted and the shield was still
down couldn't they have opened multiple
portals in the flavor core and
surrounded him a portal to the blender
dimension the one-line pitch responsible
for event horizon the factory made
cookies
flavored them with lies splenda you have
to give up something really important
for me that's my panini maker i wish for
a million sandwiches
and yes i see the irony not requesting
these sandwiches at a specific interval
so they don't arrive all at once and
spoil i wish anything about this life
would change the show does the wildest
most nonsensical [ __ ] somehow swings
it back around to make you feel
something cliche now is the time for
action sure launching the bodies out
into space gives us an idea of the
devastation evil more to conflict but it
makes a little sense in terms of
disposable especially when you've
already shown us the giant garbage
portal that seems much more suited to
the job still not curious about what
might have happened at that crazy
citadel place not at all morty that
place will never have any bearing over
our lives ever again writers let the
audience know that nothing in the show
is sacred and they'll do whatever they
please whenever they want and that
includes bringing the citadel back
probably somewhere around the 500th
season
oh geez rick oh jeez jeez oh geez oh man
oh geez hey oh geez man i hear that oh
geez but uh jeez oh geez man oh jeez
come on audrey oh jeez rick oh man oh
jeez
[Music]
sorry i
i never touched another juggler's
instruments uh yeah i think we actually
have the audio for his speech here i
just got a free churro because my mom
died the election's got these yellow
shirts more riled up than a picture day
jessica if you're gonna get nasty i'm
gonna leave yes slow rick tall morty i
said
reading is good
can we start the story now
see all you fresh-faced kidlets
sitting there in your neat little rows
and you're all just pods pods waiting
for your instructions
from the ricks and mortys that believe
in this citadel
to the ricks and mortys that don't
you're screwed thank you bye
what's
this the spice menage
they say for your wish to come true you
have to give up something really
important yeah
but you know what
this one
this one right here
this was my dream my wish
and it didn't come true